he might he might do it for the content
but
for content he might do it for the
content
he's thinking about doing it for the
content he's not thinking how to mate
here
do it for the content
[Music]
speaking of being the best space
possible i think the games are starting
in fact looks like they have and we're
off to see the wizard
with a french and we did look at this
full disclosure because benji
for the record has pretty much only
played a french
in in his uh in his chess career and so
rayne and i spent some time just looking
at the basics of the advanced variation
no trickery and you're going to see that
on the board
the craziest thing about benji is that
he's had his chess.com account since
2018.
in january of this year january 10th
his rapid rating was 817. he has gained
545 points he is currently at his peak
which he hit yesterday so this kid
and that's insane danny so i think um
the question will be interesting as to
whether
benji understands this a5 idea have him
and hammer talked about that that's a
key point in undermining the front
structure
did they not get around to that because
they didn't necessarily expect a3
i think that's going to be a key thing
in this position and we see he kind of
doesn't and he's actually blundered the
d5 pawn so
this is not working out well for benji
no it's
not and uh okay i mean the truth is that
after knight takes d5 e7 is still
protected
so computer is giving like plus four or
something completely ridiculous because
it's got a very kind of methodical way
now to pick apart everything and win but
reigns gotta see through everything like
he's gotta realize that taking on e7 is
good and then he's got to realize
like the next step it's not just winning
a pawn
is that black's position is gonna
crumble right but
gonna get spicy yeah this is the oh
okay see the problem well you know
that's a great move
uh but benji's gotta find bishop d5 like
it's a great move unless you've played
bishop d5
you gotta plug the square right yeah
good point
because yeah go ahead sorry i was gonna
say bishop yeah
bishop f7 e6 d5 i mean black resigns
black forget black stops playing the
french defense after super
f7 so i did tell i did tell rain that i
said my main goal is for you to get
hammer
to feel like he needs to switch his
students openings like that's the main
goal and he's like who's hammer
like don't worry about it yeah that i
always wonder you know in these events
like
how many of these creators know each
other like
not even by name you know just by
content all this stuff because they're
they're all over they're all working
you know maybe even hundreds of hours in
a seven day week
i'm just curious like you know do people
listen to logic's music
but put that you know and then like you
know do they watch mr b's videos there's
so many different people across so many
different
uh kind of categories but you know back
to the chess uh this is uh looking like
your guy is going to win the game
because falling apart anyway rain rain
is definitely cleaning up here so tough
lesson for benji i think that um
rayne again didn't get what we looked at
but the the goal i took as a coach
paid off because i was like look man
always what happens here is most the
time you look at these specific x's and
o's he plays a move order
one of you forgets it focus on the
forest through the trees what are you
doing here and that's really
legit is my mindset and i think it's
partly because you just have had i've
had so many experiences where
when you try to go the other way and
buckle down and say this is the exact
trap
the amount of times you get what
happened between charlie and xqc
levy is like one in a million right it
just
never works out that way so you should
focus on your bigger chess
goals rather than trying to trap people
all right i'll get off my soapbox about
coaching all right here we go
shout out to the uh the community and
the viewership we're growing here the
day's just getting started
very good okay this is an awesome
battery set up by benji
and again this is the what you would
love
to see
that is that is the most
tight rope walking way to stop that mate
danny you took the words out of my mind
i was about to say what you'd love to
see what you'd love to see
right bishop c3 is the move that's like
dude
solve the problem yeah i mean like g3
we don't even we go to break like we
don't even okay just like
there's room d8 the rook is gone no more
background problems if frank wilson
hangs back ranked mate i'll
i don't know i'll give like 500. oh my
god that movie just played
i wasn't expecting it my calves my calf
muscles tightened
i don't even have calf muscles danny i
go for a two-minute walk and i get
how do you still work out in quarantine
you still work dude i'm obsessed with
crossfit it's my only therapy
um but the gym i go to totally socially
distance and safe
what is going on here um everyone gets
their own box
and it's like it's it's away from other
people it's very very cleanly we have to
wipe down all the weights when we're
done it's actually
kind of gross the amount of uh clorox
that goes into keeping that place
covered free
i might be getting sick because of that
but that's a whole another story
queen city now rook d7 right rain's done
messing around i mean rain is uh
he sees rook d7 we're shipping it
or queen d7 but yeah rook d7 man rain
just no back rank
yeah there it is all right he smoked
this one that's
he really did that was that was actually
stunning
sometimes you can't measure that players
of all levels blunder but certainly we
know that there's a lot of blunders in
pogchamps
um but the fact that he when he wins he
just cleans up
and the fact that he um oh
speaking of he plays better when he
yeah that that really was brutal that's
not quite a game that will make you quit
the french defense
but it will definitely make you
reconsider what to play against the
advance french
uh because yeah that that that game if
anything anybody in the chat who plays
e4
and struggles with the french that was a
game to watch right there that was
that was very convincing great
okay so this is not quite what we looked
at this is already a transposition note
that benji played knight f3
d5 and d4 so we are we are
rayne is on his own i absolve myself of
all influence over the game but i did
tell him this
that if we get a queen spawn okay he
remembered that that's awesome you got
to make sure in a queens pawn game
everybody
that you can take back with a pawn
because you've got to keep that
structure together
you don't want things like this to
happen or your opponent has two pawns in
the center you don't
this is actually theory but we're not
going to get into that the point is
positionally you've really got to
protect
so i'm glad to see rain remember that
principle he will probably play g6 here
nope he didn't g6 and bishop back is is
kind of what he's familiar with king's
indian stuff so
here we go we'll see benji is really
good at these positions he likes b3
bishop b2
slow development and then later expand
with e4 he's in his wheelhouse so
okay and as i say that he plays that
move so
i think this shows he has the plan that
you're talking about living he's aware
that he needs to strive for e4 i'm with
you he needs to complete development
first
benji you got to develop and maybe even
put rooks in the center first don't
don't be in a rush to play e4 um right
but i think he has that idea in mind
well i think bishop d3 was a really
important loss of tempo because yeah
like there was no need to go bishop d3
he should have just
and now right now if reign plays e5 man
this is
no you're right actually that's right
bad
or positive i'm officially rooting for
benji in this game we want overtime
we want free chips we want pizza too
i would love some pizza i had pizza last
night at 2 a.m that's why i love new
york city yeah
that's why i'm also gaining too much
weight but
it was it was amazing man pepperoni
right out there right out the oven oh so
good
oh my god rain rain's in his own today i
can feel it yeah you've seen the board
well
e5 is a great move such a problem is
that you don't you didn't need to make
that move your bishop was
not really changing too much you know
what the computer is suggesting here
c5 by black which just looks like a
mouse
that's the best move and then it wants
knight a4
and that's why your valve bar is so
deceiving get ready for this eval bar to
go nuts everybody because i don't think
see
and here you go rain plays queen e7 as
much as we were plotting e5
and i think it was rightfully so i think
rain is seeing the board well
and he clearly saw this idea but the
truth is
it may have been a little bit of a too
advanced follow-up because now
now he's going to get himself in trouble
yeah d takes c6 now benji's got to get
that tunnel vision
i benji's got to realize e4 is not a
threat which i think is why he played
bishop d3 he was so worried about the e4
square
but there's no threat like right you're
fine just
take the pawn on c6 probably don't take
twice
because the rook will come to c8 and hit
the knight and maybe it works i haven't
done fulham here and actually you know
calculated but
now rain is now rain is going off the
deep end here
oh man rain's gone wild i think they
both have just miscalculated the pieces
on that square
rain is avoiding trades which this is a
this is a good idea i think
conceptually when you're like i'm losing
i need to keep the pieces on the board
but rook cd8 is actually a big mistake
if benji sees bishop a3
because this rook here is running out of
squares um oh it looks like benji has
played a5
and knight b5 so that was that was a
missed opportunity from benji
bishop a3 would have been pretty nice
and that's what the computer liked um
rook c6 now probably just to tag the
queen
but yeah white is still better well rain
is keeping this close benji now at two
minutes and 20 seconds
but if the a5 pawn falls there it goes
yeah this is still still
anyone's game and actually remember all
rain needs is a draw
to punch his ticket to the championship
so we are all rooting for benji we want
overtime here
but but the advantage has slipped away
where
oh i don't like that oh i don't like
that huge mistake knight h5
knight h5 or any knight move this is not
a move that rain
uh wants to play that is terribly
weakening to his king side
oh knight h5 just sneak in oh man
the thing that is a minute h5 is now
you've got back rank threats
um yeah g7 is covered oh that's
two wrong way that's too sober of a move
you need to get weird with it i almost
wonder if benji's just a little i don't
want to say intimidating
he's a little nervous right i feel like
he knows reign is the strongest player
he's faced yet
and he's not playing as aggressive as we
saw him clean up some of the other
matches he had right i mean i feel like
he's playing a little timid here
was that a slip or does he want to play
a5 rook b8 there was really good
but okay rook 8 is fine as well yeah
yeah this is surgical now will rain
realize he can trade queens
and push the pawn it's actually his best
move even though ironically
okay and he does it doesn't ironically
he takes and here comes a5 and now if
you're benji
oh no he doesn't know a5 e4 just go e45
oh wrong pawn neither player is using
their pawn advantage
use your pawn advantage or
king g4 now wrong way okay i
think king of five and veggie wins the
game he played it i think benji is going
to win this game and we're going to have
overtime kids
does rain find rook a5 only move
so that if king g5 i guess at least wow
oh my gosh reigns gonna save it same way
he did with charlie
crazy i thought there's nothing i mean
the pawn is just yeah now king e5 now
black is winning no
oh no wow
oh no oh my gosh
brain's winning the king of pawn ending
it's unbelievable benji can do only
benji can only draw oh it's a draw now
yeah but it's it doesn't it's over i
know oh i know he's gonna say
joshua chamberlain strikes again
it's uh yeah he was winning and then he
had to actually you know
it's never too late but i think rain
doesn't really care because yeah
obviously he can't win just with the
king so
oh man the cinderella story man like
winning the group the only man to have
beaten start ocean i hit the head but
we're not gonna get to see the rematch
yeah it's funny because benji's probably
a tougher matchup for sardoche i don't
know how well rain will handle
litz against sardoche but um if it goes
to an overtime tiebreaker but
wow what a heartbreaker for benji he was
totally winning in game two
not what you saw coming
king a6 king c6 maybe 16.6 is the recipe
you need
they'll mate stephen it is he might he
might do it for the content but
for content he might do it for the
content
he's thinking about doing it for the
content he's not thinking how to mate
here
do it for the content rain
eclipse can only be a minute long oh
queen c6
i really should learn how to do that end
game
no i mean i still won
uh i should have been able to to meet
you there i just
i should have taken my time wow what a
game jeez
benji starting with you i know this
didn't go the way you you wanted it to
today but a super close match
and uh what were your thoughts on on
where it got away
from you or any of your takeaways from
this
um i don't know i think i don't think it
was no
i mean the first game i just made a
stupid blunder and i
rained played really good i couldn't it
was really hard for me to come back
um in the second game uh i was winning
and then
the time pressure just got to me and i
yeah started panicking a bit
um that was basically it for me but rain
played
played really good first game was about
as solid as game as i've
played in a long time and i felt really
good about that and he
blundered and gave up his bishop there
and then kind of got on the ropes and
had pieces forked so i did get a little
lucky there
but it was a solid game and the second
game
um i don't know he had um
it was something i just wasn't used to
that
uh the way the center was locked up and
it's one of those things you have to be
like how much pressure is on each pawn
like i've got a knight on the pawn and a
bishop on a pawn and a queen on a pawn
and i've got this
pawn on the pawn and and i just lost
track of
of that and in my head i saw this fork i
was like
oh there's a fork with the queen and the
bishop and but i didn't even have the
fork it wasn't even real because his
knight was there so i don't know what i
was thinking but i just
my brain just kind of shut down in that
little middle part of the game in the in
the second game and then
um and then and then i'm like listen
he's up three points
um uh i think i play a little faster
than he does
so let me just hang in there solid as
long as i can and
maybe pawn by pawn claw my way up back
which i did
for a large chunk of it and then he got
a really good end game strategy
and if he had rammed those pawns down my
king's throat i would have been
dead as a doornail but um
i got lucky because of the time pressure
as well and then at the end
danny you never taught me how to mate
with a king and a queen against the cage
i knew you were going to blame me for
that
that's what you teach five-year-olds
when they're learning chess and i don't
so it's danny's fault
[Music]
you